les équipes du transporteur prévaut
doivent être très fébrile ce soir
puisque l'entreprise québécoise lance
une nouvelle version de son modèle
d'autocar le plus connu après une
période plus difficile prévaut à
maintenant résolument mis le pied sur
l'accélérateur on va faire le point avec
François Tremblay et les présidents de
Prévost et Volvo bus à mairie du Nord
bonsoir monsieur Tremblay
bonsoir madame
vous présenter donc une nouvelle version
du modèle d'autocar le h345 ça se passe
ce soir à Orlando devant tous les
acteurs de l'industrie c'est majeur pour
prévôt monsieur Tremblay il faut
rappeler c'est une entreprise de
Sainte-Claire dans chaudière à palache
là gros marché grosses pour vous ce soir
une très grosse annonce parce que c'est
notre véhicule
flightship comme on dit effectivement
donc c'est un gros lancement puis ça
fait du bien aussi d'avoir des bonnes
nouvelles annonce au marché surtout
après deux ans et demi qui ont été plus
difficiles lié à la pandémie donc pour
l'instant prévu ce soir devant
exactement une fois l'intérieur on est
dans une industrie présentement dans un
des plus gros événements de l'industrie
qui commence le début d'année donc c'est
l'endroit parfait idéal pour introduire
notre plus beau véhicules bon rapidement
à monsieur Tremblay qu'est-ce qu'il a de
spécial qu'est-ce qu'il a de plus ce
nouveau véhicule
de longueur depuis plusieurs années au
travail pour optimiser ce qui est
intéressant là-dessus c'est qu'on
voulait s'assurer qu'il y a un bénéfice
tant pour les passagers que pour les
conducteurs que même les propriétaires
donc un des gros éléments on aurait
désigné le véhicule pour vraiment
améliorer l'aérodynamisme et on a
travaillé beaucoup d'éléments qui nous a
amenés même une économie d'essence
substantielle et de taux de 12%. donc
évidemment pour les compagnies qui font
énormément de millage ça va se
matérialiser en beaucoup de de ces vins
en termes de coups d'opération vous
imaginer on a travaillé aussi beaucoup
modernisé tous les intérieurs pour
rendre ça au bout du jeu parce que le
véhicule avait quand même déjà quelques
années derrière lui donc on a vraiment
moderniser les intérieurs beaucoup
d'aspects aussi sur la sécurité on
amélioré l'environnement chauffeur
meilleure visibilité aussi en réduisant
les obstructions pour s'assurer
justement une meilleure visibilité quand
les chauffeurs utilisent des véhicules
dans les environnements urbains donc
plein de petites choses comme ça qui ont
qui vont vraiment amener le véhicule au
panoplie de segments de marché le plus
gros segment va être évidemment les
opérateurs pour le tourisme ou pour
l'intercité donc un peu on connaît bien
les express de ce monde au Québec mais
green ainsi de suite pour définitivement
des bons achats pour ce véhicule et
aussi on a dérivé avec cette même
semaine véhicule là où sont des
applications pour les maisons motorisées
donc même nos clients propriétaires de
maison motorisées vont pouvoir
bénéficier du nouveau design de ce
véhicule bon monsieur Tremblay Prévost
fait partie ce groupe Volvo depuis
plusieurs années maintenant mais
l'entreprise est toujours bien présente
à Sainte-Claire est-ce que les véhicules
ceux que vous présentez ce soir le h345
est-ce qu'ils seront produits chez nous
et oui exactement ils vont être 100%
aussi c'est que une grosse partie de nos
exportations sont ouverts donc autour de
85 % des de tout ce qui est produit à
sainte-clair s'en va vers le marché
américain donc c'est une très belle
c'était très belle retombées pour le
Québec on a énormément de fournisseurs
aussi établi au Québec donc il y a des
retombées économiques importantes puis
effectivement donc tous ces véhicules
vont être effectivement produit à
Saint-Clair donc ça va amener évidemment
création d'emplois parce que la demande
déjà continue d'augmenter on est en
train de d'augmenter nos cadences de
production donc on est en grosse période
de recrutement présentement d'ailleurs
vous avez même dépassé votre niveau de
vente d'avant la pandémie qu'est-ce qui
explique que ça va si bien chez Prévost
en ce moment
ça explique en fait plusieurs choses
c'est que la première c'est que le récit
de retour du pendent du pendule en fait
ça va être tellement intelligent durant
la pandémie évidemment puis les
opérateurs dans l'industrie n'ayant pas
acheter le véhicule il y avait comme une
demande d'attente qui s'est créée donc
là ils ont besoin de Ré acheter des
véhicules pour rajeunir leurs flottes
donc ça c'est un des premiers éléments
un deuxième élément c'est qu'on a eu une
bonne croissance de part de marché aux
actions qu'on a pris durant la pandémie
pour le contenu investir dans les
nouveautés comme le produit on va voir
ce soir donc le marché bien répondu donc
en fait on a beaucoup même d'opérateurs
de la compétition qui sont vendus
vouloir faire affaire avec nous donc le
fait d'augmenter aussi la part de marché
cela a aidé donc c'est un peu tout ça
qui a fait finalement que les nouveautés
la compétition justement qui a été faite
un peu plus au ralenti puis on a pris un
peu le moment puis le retour comme je
vous dis de l'industrie tout ça fait que
l'industrie va très bien présentement
c'est l'inflation qui doit
nécessairement toucher les prix de beaux
intrants peut-être que ça a fait que
même les prix de vente et l'appétit des
acheteurs de quelle manière ça impacte
votre entreprise
en fait c'est une très bonne question et
puis en fait dans notre industrie à deux
niveaux vous avez effectivement mis le
doigt sur le bon rond-point c'est que
les intrants le coût des pièces
énormément augmenter le coût de la
matière première donc le coût de nos
véhicules par défaut augmenté puis
l'autre est fait aussi c'est que vous
avez vous êtes au courant les taux
d'intérêt aussi augmenter de façon
significative au cours de la dernière
année donc en plus d'avoir un véhicule
qui est plus dispendieux il est plus
coûteux aussi tout dispendieux financer
donc ça a eu quand même des gros impacts
ceci étant dit ce qui est intéressant
c'est que nos clients ont été capables
de repasser ces augmentations là à leur
propre client donc un taux capable
d'augmenter leur taux journalier donc en
bout de ligne il s'en sort quand même
relativement bien parce que tout le
monde s'attendait en fait qu'il y a une
autre suite à tout ce qu'on voit on
n'est pas la seule industrie qui écopé
on regarde tous les biens de
consommation autour de nous on vécu la
même chose donc les gens s'attendaient
très bien merci beaucoup monsieur
Tremblay je vous souhaite un bel
événement et un bon lancement ce soir
c'est bien gentil au plaisir merci
encore madame simplement pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez-vous sur la
chaîne ici RDI